shley dangling Puck was off a stick and out of
the Zone shley with his 273rd career goal on
Wednesday in the loss against the Flames
Jets regroup pass through shley right in
scores mark shley flying up the middle of the
ice his second of the Season gives the Jets the
lead check the counter out here Josh morsey unable
to keep the puck alive so they sort things out
watch this sweet dish from Kyle Conor he pulls
the attention to him three Florida Panthers eyes
on number 81 that opens up a Lane right there and
a perfectly placed pass from Connor onto the Stick
of shle who does not have to break stride and
now has goals in back-to-back games the first
clicks it back off escap and it'll be lugged
ahead by balinskis 27y old defenseman looking
up on the wing Carter hey in tight went short
side stop made by H up ahead is Josh Morris he
here he comes Mory off that right wing he's got
a man and shley shoots a rebound and shley just
couldn't get to it in time Baron and Kar are the
forwards Samberg and D are the defenseman to start
this second penalty field of the first period
for Winnipeg in come the Panthers good pass to
Rodriguez side of the net feed and Reinhardt the
tip in goal terrific Puck Movement by the they tie
it at one on the power play oh this is brilliant
this is Vision try to disrupt up the ice and then
back come the Panthers I believe this is Evan
Rodriguez in the slot and he just one touches
this to Reinhardt who doesn't have much of an
angle and just slides it in he has barely the
geometry to tuck this in behind Conor heluk that
was a pretty play a trifecta that leads to the
game's tying goal on the power play for Florida
but a bit quicker and I think that puck Pace in
the power play has confused the penalty kill of
their opponent so far they're getting some good
looks so they start the Lowry line with the
power play just about over the second period
is underway and now Appleton will send that into
Panthers ice Lowry gets a step on the play works
it back to the line there's for hay he was in the
Box he'll just pick it up and head the other way
barov take the backhand pass so hard to get the
puck away from him with that reach and strength
kulakov thr shot through a crow they score the
rebound Rodriguez at the goal mouth 25 seconds
into the second about not just shooting the
puck but when he shoots it he's going to wait
for traffic and there it is and then a shot
through traffic hoping for a rebound that's
exactly what he gets there's Rodriguez on the
doorstep two Florida Panthers proves to be too
much to handle for hell Evan Rodriguez a
two-point day so far gardi redirects head
in shley get it behind SOS gavic he curl behind
the net sets It Up Up Carter shoots and scores
10 seconds after the Panthers goal they answer
back immediately Kyle Conor with his second the
big boys doing big boy things here countering
right you get a bump up shift and and what do
you do with it well the first thing win the
face off and then can you get the first touch
well Mark shley does that on the four check
a wraparound pass and Kyle Conor finds a soft
space in the slot and he's not going to miss from
there very often Waring came right to him Gabriel
nice pass Conor B the point pass turning off the
czecher blondel to the front of the net and he's
stopped there by bosski Conor authoritative move
and they almost took the lead right backora low
shot releasing his Neer rider for fet goes left
side Nikolai heers leader right to the front of
the goal Mar he got it was in and he's pointing
we'll see if there's a review back at the point
Dylan and in transition Samos gavage nice back
check by eers he's got speed and he Kyle Conor
elers cares it kick save by bosski calling
forward at the line was Rasmus gari he'll
rush in lifting The Stick of mahura he wins the
battle Kari steps out on the back hand now Kari
tried to back it off and in and bar [Applause]
stores the Jets taking pucks to the net Morgan
bars first makes it 3-2 winter pick come to
fruition it was aalo battling netfront last
shift that led to this for check from Rasmus
kupari he strips the puck and gets it into
danger net front there's the shot there's the
rebound and there's the third looking to work
it back to the blue line but now instead to the
corner Heelers avoids a check eer Ryder Ekman
Larson on him Ean Larson lost his stick eer
Ryder ni Peretti out front it's C with a dby
starts
Dylan Dello with a wrist shot his first and it's
42 WI a pick just outstanding work down in the
corners from neita Rider we talked earlier about
that blue collar mentality a nice little cycle
job Peretti spins and fires a beautiful pass to
a weak side Dem man and Dylan Dello doesn't disa
Point weak side there's time when he goes cross
graen he beats and the penalty is over Here Comes
Nate Smith drops it off for nestic off out front
of the backand rebound Lowry is denied and Nika
took a r at him and went flying Mark Shipley
shooting percentage is always really high two
goals on the season four shots he never wastes
one does he he knows the right time to pass and
when he shoots it not often does he miss Ean
Larson walking the line Rodriguez his crossy
speed not played cleanly by kachuk Lowry lost
his stick but boot it ahead he gets a stick in
full flight Lowry for appeton stop by is it in
it's more appon puts it in shorthanded goal 52
jets are you ready for this Lowry no stick is
Mory going to get a second assist for this one
as he dishes off The Twig Lowry makes the pass
to the middle of the ice and it's the fifth goal
of the game how about that no qu in Low's game
he uses his foot to Mory stick to the Stick of
Appleton and this place is bumping Dan what a
beautiful sequence of heads up play from Josh
Morrison you'd love to see the goalie try for
a goal not that time a pass ahead Rodriguez
into the Zone he gets through he'll have to
play it off the back fors took a hit from pan
went hurdling into him there's a shot C by hu
and they score in the rebound for heggy found
the loose Puck and it's 5 to three wiip pick
in all of the NHL last year so they're a team
that you know can score goals and down by three
their risk profile will go up as they push in
the Carter haggy last year a career year with
42 goals shot rebound is perfectly placed by
Mark shley no icing Rodriguez will turn into
it for Florida still with the empty net of
course to Reinhardt cross ice barkov shoots
and scores and with 224 to go it's five to
four there's not three different times
in this entire game that that I've seen
the Jets maybe guilty of backing off here
a little bit they got beat flat footed in
the neutral zone and now look at that second
layer it's barov the sharp shooter comes to
the second layer and gets the pass he wants
he's able to beat Connor hel the BR I he's
going to go to the bench extra skater coming
on now for the Panthers they're short-handed
Mory fans yelling shoot he finds Conor to the
empty n [Applause] scor Conor with his second
of the day third of the Season 64 WI a f not
the post and then the other way we go good
patience Mory scans and he finds the safe play
to the we the Jets will get their first win of
the Season it comes here at home they beat the
Panthers 6 to four and it's all [Applause] over